FAILURE ALONE, THE SAME POLICY
SET UP AND FAILING COMMUNITIES
FOR DECADES.
HERE WITH REACTION, WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
THE PRESIDENT DID HELP OUT, DID
HE NOT, IN WASHINGTON, D.C.?
THE PRESIDENT DID HELP OUT IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
AND IN THOSE TWO AREAS, WE SAW A
DRAMATIC CHANGE, DIDN’T WE?
>> WELL, WE SAW A DRAMATIC
CHANGE, SEAN COME IN THE TRAGIC
NEWS THAT YOU ARE SHARING
TONIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT’S GOING TO
REPEAT ITSELF OVER AND OVER
AGAIN IF WE DO NOT GET BEHIND
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT, IF WE DO
NOT MAKE SURE THAT WE STAND STAN
FOR LAW AND ORDER.
THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING EXACTLY
THAT.
IN FACT, HE’S THE ONLY THING
THAT STANDS BETWEEN A MOB IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FIRST IT’S THE STATUES.
THEN IT’S THE BUSINESSES.
THEN IT’S THEIR HOMES.
SADLY, WE HAVE A LOSS OF LIFE
AND YET THIS PRESIDENT IS
WILLING AND NOT ONLY WILLING BUT
HAS ALREADY PUT FORTH FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN RESTORE LAW AND ORDER.
HE DID THAT ABOUT TEN DAYS AGO.
NOT ONLY IN D.C. BUT ACROSS THE
NATION.
THAT’S THE UNTOLD STORY WHERE
THIS PRESIDENT WAS WILLING AND
DID INDEED PROVIDE FEDERAL
RESOURCES IN MINNEAPOLIS, AS YOU
MENTION.
ALSO IN SEATTLE.
PORTLAND.
WHEN WE LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
CITIES, ST. LOUIS, AS HE GOES
FORWARD, HE’S MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE NOT ONLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND OTHERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE SAFE.
IT IS TIME THAT JOE BIDEN
EVENTUALLY CONDEMNS ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SAYING THAT WE
SHOULD DEFUND THE POLICE.
IT’S NOT ENOUGH TO BE AGAINST
THAT POLICY.
HE NEEDS TO COME OUT AND SAY,
YOU HAVE TO GO THE OTHER WAY AND
SUPPORT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, ALL THE
DEMOCRATS, MODERN DEMOCRATS
PRAISING THE FORMER KLANSMAN
ROBERT KKK BERG, JOE BIDEN
COMMENTS ON SEGREGATION,
INTEGRATION, THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA IGNORE THIS, MARK MEADOWS,
PRESIDENT BY THE WAY VERY HIGHLY
RATED ON FRIDAY NIGHT,
HIS SPEECH AT MOUNT RUSHMORE
AND I WATCHED HIS SPEECH ON
SATURDAY NIGHT, THE
FOURTH OF JULY.
THERE IS NO PERFECT COUNTRY IN
THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
MY FRIEND GARY FARBER RECENTLY
PASSED AWAY, GREAT PIONEER AND
TALK RADIO.
THERE IS NO COUNTRY IN THE FACE
OF THE EARTH THAT CIRCULATED
MORE POWER, ABUSED IT LESS THAN
THIS ONE.
I ADD AND USE THAT POWER FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF THE HUMAN
CONDITION.
AMERICA, MARK MEADOWS, WE PAY
THE PRICE.
WE BEAT BACK THE FORCES, AS THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT, IN HIS
SPEECHES OF FASCISM, NAZISM,
IMPERIAL JAPAN, COMMUNISM, AND
NOW MORE RECENTLY RADICAL
ISLAMISM.
AMERICA DID THAT AND MADE THE
WORLD HAVE BETTER, SAFER PLACE.
THAT’S MAYBE ONE OF THE REASON
SO MANY PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD
WANT TO COME INTO AMERICA AND WE
ARE BUILDING WALLS TO VET PEOPLE
PEOPLE.
>> YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT, SEAN.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS, IMPERFECT
MEN THAT TRULY FOUNDED THIS
NATION ON JUDEO-CHRISTIAN VALUES
THAT SAID WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
FORM A MORE PERFECT UNION.
INDEED EACH AND EVERY DAY HAS
BEEN AN ADVANCEMENT OF THAT TO
MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY THE BEST
COUNTRY ON THE FACE OF THE GLOBE
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE
CONTINUE TO STAND UP FOR THOSE
VALUES, FOR THOSE WHO CAN’T
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN WILLING
TO DO THAT.
YOU MENTIONED THE SPEECH THERE
AND MOUNT RUSHMORE.
NOT ONLY WAS IT A HISTORIC
SPEECH, BUT HE LAID OUT REALLY
THE DIFFERENCE.
ARE WE GOING TO BE FOR ANARCHY?
OR ARE WE GOING TO BE FOR THE
RULE OF LAW AND MAKING SURE THAT
AMERICAN CITIZENS FEEL SAFE ONCE
AGAIN IN THEIR HOMES?
THIS PRESIDENT IS WILLING TO DO
THAT.
WHERE IS JOE BIDEN?
IN HIS BASEMENT.
YOU KNOW, IT’S AMAZING.
WE HAVE SEEN JOE BIDEN FOR 40
YEARS TALK A GOOD GAME.
NO RESULTS.
>> Sean: 51.
125 YEARS COMBINED FAILURE, HIM,
PELOSI, AND SCHUMER.
>> AS WE LOOK AT THAT, IT’S NOT
ONLY THAT THEY ARE JUST TALKING
IN GOOD GAME BUT THEY FAILED TO
ACT.
WHEN THEY FAIL TO ACT, THEY ARE
REAL CONSEQUENCES TO THAT
SADLY WE ARE SEEING EACH AND
EVERY DAY, THE CONSEQUENCES
REALLY ARE PLAYED OUT ON
MAIN STREET ACROSS AMERICA.
WE HAVE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT, AND THE TIME IS NOW.
THIS PRESIDENT IS COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT.
HE’S INSTRUCTED HIS ENTIRE TEAM
TO WORK ON IT.
>> Sean: AMERICA WILL BE
UNRECOGNIZABLE IF IT’S PELOSI,
SCHUMER, AND BIDEN AND THE
IMPLEMENT THIS INSANE AGENDA.
BY THE WAY, I TOLD YOU YOU
WEREN’T GOING TO LEAVE
PERMANENTLY.
I DID TWIST YOUR ARM A LITTLE
BIT ON NATIONAL TV.